Harry and Megan have been celebrating
Archie's first birthday by reading him a
story the video posted on Instagram by
Save the Children Megan is seen sat in
an armchair with Archie on her lap let's
take a listen Hey look a duck it's not a
duck can you turn the page what happens
after that are you kidding me it's
totally a duck it's for sure a rabbit
see there's his bill think about those
are his ears silly it's a duck and he's
about to eat a piece of bread
well skies are old correspondent Brandon
Mills joins me now and Rhiannon why they
why they released this well what year it
has been I remember being there in
Windsor twelve months ago waiting for
the news that Archie had been born and I
think from that very moment we knew that
the parents were going to be fiercely
protective of his privacy so it was
always going to be interesting to see
exactly how they decided to mark his
first birthday especially when you
consider that they're no longer using
their Sussex royal Instagram accounts
they can't use that brand anymore so
instead they decided to team up with
Save the Children to post what is a very
sweet video indeed it's because Save the
Children have this campaign at the
moment which is called save with stories
where they're encouraging people to
think about the impact that kovat 19 and
the coronavirus crisis is having on
children around the world so yeah of
course we're all going to watch it
because this is a rare opportunity for
us to see how Archie is growing up and
doesn't he look like his dad and but if
the Sussex is they decided that they
really wanted to as they say in their
post they wanted to celebrate this
family moment and they wanted to
continue to raise awareness around the
urgency of bringing food and learning
resources to millions of children and
that's the reason that the Duchess chose
to read one of Archie's favorite stories
duck rabbit now other members of the
family have also wished Archie a public
Happy Birthday via their Twitter feeds
and of course it has been an incredible
year for the Sussex is I suspect
whatever has been going on behind the
scenes with of course all those family
fallings out that we've talked about so
much I suspect there will still be a
number of phone calls taking place from
here in the UK over to America on what
is a very special day for Harry Megan
and one-year-old Archie Rhiannon thanks
very much